hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days today's day number 29 and we're
gonna just do something a little simple
we're gonna be creating a blurry depth
of field blur your images on blurrier
images effect whatever we want to call
it essentially you can make images and
elements blurry and transition in and
out of that blurred effect to whatever
degree that you wish with just css3 now
typically before you'd have to do this
with photoshop or maybe even like a
jQuery plugin or something like that but
we can do that in css3 and it's really
cool now it's quite simple in its you
know in its basic form but you can do a
lot with it if you had layered elements
and you wanted certain elements to be
blurry in the background and certain
ones to be to be focused in the front
like a legitimate depth of field effect
where you your your focus point is on a
specific layer and then the other ones
come in and out of focus you can play
around with that but in this case I'm
gonna show you just simply how the blur
effect works and we're just gonna to
blur a none blur and transition in and
out of that so with css3 so here we go
day 29 the blurry effects so we just
have four images here that are just
standard stock images but down here what
we're gonna do is we're going to have
them start out as blurry once we kind of
hover in view and then when you focus on
one it will kind of come forward and be
within focus with the other ones be
being blurring the background when we
hover out of that it should go back to
its blurred state and we can also hover
to a different one able to switch and
now that one is in focus this one is in
focus this one is it focus a good
practical example of practical use of
this specific demo would be perhaps
portfolio images or a gallery of images
now the blur effect here is quite
dramatic now you don't have to have it
be that dramatic of a blurred effect but
maybe in some cases that might be what
you want so let's jump into our code
editor download day number 29 and then
as you can see in our markup here we
simply just have four images there's
nothing crazy about this at all it's
quite
hit your sandbox and let's start coding
so we're gonna select the depth gallery
that is the div that wraps the four
images and we're simply just going to
position:relative and then
display:inline-block then we're going to
select the depth gallery image so all
the images we're going to give them a
border of solid let's do 8 pixels or 7
doesn't really matter white box shadow
we're going to go 0 0 5 pixels and then
rgba 0 0 0 and then 0.3
and then we'll say cursor:pointer
because we're hovering over it we want
that interaction you don't have to you
can change it to crosshair let's do that
I'd be fun and we're gonna say
transition we're in a transition the
filter property because we're gonna be
using the css3 filter property I'll show
you in a moment here 0.3 seconds linear
we're also going to transition the
transform property at 0.3 seconds and
linear as well save that now if you go
to our browser you can see the images
now have a nice little like a nice
border a white a white border around it
with a little bit of a shadow it's just
a nice a nice way of displaying an image
just makes it look nice gives it a frame
now we're gonna go back here we're gonna
say depth gallery hover when you hover
over the entire depth gallery and then
image so when you hover over that
element the entire parent element parent
element do something with the images and
that's simply going to be filter so we
can apply some graphical effects we're
gonna say blur and then 5 pixels so
that's how you do that that's how you
blur an image check it out so when I
hover it in there so I'm out of the
element itself when I have her into that
element it's going to blur everything 5
pixels now you can have it be more
exaggerated or less exaggerated by
changing the value higher or lower this
is one pixel very subtle and if I did 10
pixels you can't even recognize what the
image is really
so there we go I'm gonna stick with
let's say four pixels and I'm gonna
transform it and I'm gonna use the scale
value here and scale is simply just the
size the scale of it I want it be wine
would equal it's not gonna do anything
it's gonna be its normal size 0.9 is
ninety percent of its size both height
and width you can have it be two and
it'll be twice the size so you can scale
an element any element using transform
scale save it
now when I hover into the depth gallery
everything shrinks 0.9 and goes blurry
to four pixel blur effect okay and the
only thing we have to do now is when you
hover over say depth gallery image and
then hover over an individual image
we're going to filter we're gonna
overwrite that filter property and blur
to zero so just back to a standard
InFocus image transform scale and then
1.1 and because we're transitioning the
image is everything is got a nice kind
of fluid transition in between so save
it now let's check it out we hovered in
everything goes down to 0.9 and goes
blurry you hover over one comes up into
focus and is a little bit larger when
you hover out onto a different one the
one goes back one comes forward nice and
simple so that's it for today's demo for
the blurry effect we simply played
around with filters the filter blur and
the transform scale you could do
everything from transforming and
rotating upon that when you hover but
because this was about blurring images
we're simply using the filter blur
effect I challenge you to take this a
little bit further I showed you how to
use the blur and transition in between
in focus and everything like that but I
challenge you to do something exciting
with this maybe have the images
individually be stacked in front of each
other have them be cascading out in
front of each other so you could see an
image and then one in front and a little
bit down and another one
front a little bit down and so on and so
forth and when you hover over that image
you know maybe pop it out of like a deck
of cards and have it come in focus and
the other ones go blurry or maybe you
will you have separate individual PNG
transparent elements like a scene you
have maybe three trees or something like
that and when you hover over one tree
that one's in focus you hover over this
one it's in focus the other two are
blurry almost like if you were a
photographer and you're you're
photographing someone and you want to
put a certain element in focus and have
you know the background be blurry and
the foreground be blurry but this one
single plane of focus that's kind of
what you're doing here so I challenge
you to experiment with this and don't
just leave it here I've given you the
tool and now I want you to play with it
a bit so see what you can come up with
and I will see you in tomorrow's final
lesson day number 30 so I'll see you
there and have fun with blur effect
[Music]